لا مافيش حظر
المناهج عايزه بدايه من الجذور انت في
حاجه الى مناهج تبني العقليه انت في حاجه
الا مناهج تبني الفكر انت في حاجه الى
مناهج تتبنى قضيه الحوار انك تتقبل رايك
وتتقبل الراي الاخر يعني انا مثلا اقول لك
حاجه عند ابي حنيفه مثلا وهي كلمه لطيفه
وطريفه لما تلامذته قاعدين معه بيقولوا له
يا امام لعل الذي تقوله هو الحق الذي لم
يريت فيه الا لعله الباطل الذي لم فيه شوف
هذه الكلمه يعني هو لا يحصر الحق انت لو
نزلت تقول انت بتقول هو الحق الذي لا يعمل
لعله الباطل الذي لم يريت فيه فلوغه
الحوار مش موجوده البناء العلمي والفكري
والثقافي للاولاد لغايه ما طلعوا في
الدراسات الشرعيه مش موجوده هي عباره عن
مذكرات في الجامعات يحفظها الاستاذ الطالب
زي ما الاستاذ قال له يخش يحطها في الورقه
صحيح الامام الاكبر بقى له فتره بيحاول
يجدد ويعمل منال طليع يعني
وفيلسوف وكذا الى اخره لكن الموضوع كبير
جدا ومتشعب يحتاج الى
جامعات يحتاج الى كبار المثقفين